Responsive patterns are quickly
evolving, but there are a handful of
established patterns that work well,
across pretty much any device.
Most patterns used by responsive web
pages can be categorized into one of
four patterns, mostly fluid, column
drop, layout shifter, and off canvas.
In some cases, a page may use
a combination of patterns.
For example, column drop and off canvas.
In each of these examples, and
the examples moving forward, the colored
boxes represent areas of content.
Let's break them down one by one.
I'm going to show you how these
patterns work, and then using your
Flexbox skills and media queries, you're
going to practice implementing them.